this meat smells weird today is a dark
day
I just want real food today I have to go
vegan so last week I lost a bet to my
friend Carrie is one of the best vegan
news we've ever had it is I lost and I
will be vegan for a week and I survive
and I will survive
Carrie actually sent me a message I just
realized that you have to eat vegan for
a week enjoy eating your veggies okay
here's the deal I fully support veganism
I've heard all the facts about being a
vegan I just it's not for me I just
started doing keto I'm all down for
eating a plant-based diet but when I'm
doing keto carbs on a part of it so I
can't eat beans I can't eat quinoa I
don't know how I'm gonna get protein in
this diet I don't want to have to give
up eggs and salmon and bacon I refuse to
eat tofu I really really don't want to
eat tofu now I have to figure out what
I'm gonna go eat today for the next
seven days I'm gonna go online and do as
much research as possible to try to find
out how to do this I did not plan this
out too well today day one I was not
able to eat anything in our free lunch
that we got I had to suck it up and
basically just have some almond butter
and some avocado also went and bought
some MCT oil that I'm gonna put in some
coffee to try to fill me up but I need
to go to the store tonight to make sure
I can get some protein at the end of the
first day I was planning on going to the
store but I had to work really late and
I didn't get a chance to go to the store
so I'm not vegetarian or vegan but I am
doing this thing where I have to eat
vegan keto right now can I just do the
Beyond eyes well the patty like the
beyond burger patty this is all brand
new to me so
I'm pretty lucky I live in a city like
la it makes doing this vegan thing so
much easier I don't know if I'd be able
to do something like this in another
part of the country so being a vegan is
definitely kind of a privilege one of
the things I realized early on with this
diet is you really have to plan ahead
alright so I just finished my morning
workout and normally this is the time
when I'm gonna go and try to have some
breakfast probably eat some eggs some
avocado something like that some of the
fits in the keto diet I can't have eggs
I need to go to the store let some vegan
protein powder I'm gonna have to prep
every single meal and cook ahead of time
especially since I'm not trying to eat
tofu no tofu all right so we got some
just beyond chicken I'm a big texture
guy when it comes to food so this is
throwing me off I don't know jury's
still out either way I'm gonna eat it
because any protein and this is all I
got so I hope you're enjoying this Kari
I didn't have time this morning to make
myself something and I forgot to make a
protein shake to bring with me so I was
really really hungry just had a little
bit of almond butter forgot to bring a
hot picado so this is the thing where I
really really have to try hard to make
sure that I'm doing it the right way so
I love Thai food I'm meeting a friend
here at a vegan Thai place see how this
goes I'm gonna try some of this soy
chicken I'm not very excited I just want
real meat you know what I mean this is
pretty good I'm having a big craving for
cheeseburgers I'm gonna try to make
myself a vegan bacon cheeseburger I am
not very confident this bacon doesn't
look
well it doesn't look like bacon okay if
you can bake and here we go it kind of
reminds me a turkey bacon it's not bad
it's definitely not bacon but it can
kind of satisfy that craving one gram of
fat two grams of protein since I'm doing
keto I would like there to be more fat
in the bacon which real bacon actually
has so kind of missing out on that which
means I have to substitute something
else to get extra fat see and keto is so
much easier where you can actually eat
real meat real eggs and things like that
this actually tastes pretty damn good
I'm not gonna lie but the only issue I
have with it is that it has four grams
of carbs and zero protein if I'm eating
real cheese I'm gonna be getting more
fat less carbs and more protein overall
this is good so the funny thing about
vegans is that as soon as they hear that
you're gonna try being vegan every one
of them is really really helpful and
wants to try to help you so what are we
making we talked about tofu I don't like
it's high protein tofu which are those
your kids a lot of grams of protein 2
grams of carbs let's do this
[Applause]
[Music]
y'all heard me at the beginning I said
no tofu I said none so I've already
broken my rule but here we go
this is so good do I think it would be
better with regular protein maybe but
right now I can't even tell the
difference honestly this tofu is really
good the texture is good this is
fantastic this is fantastic
mmm this is good that's all I have to
say we're done
I'm definitely getting the hang of this
whole vegan keto thing brought the curry
to work to eat so once she's done
[Music]
I last day of being a vegan I'm not
gonna lie it feels good but you know
what to be honest I haven't actually
been missing food too much I've been
going through a jar every other day in
this almond butter now I'm literally
eating my own words as I said I would
not eat so food this is the second dish
I've had with tofu in two days this is a
tofu scramble it's pretty good all right
so foo I like it I may have overreacted
with my initial hatred for tofu that
vegan curry was one of the best things
I've ever had I still crave it and the
thing I really liked about having to do
this was it it took me out of my comfort
zone and it taught me how to cook new
things and try things I had not tried
before moving forward I doubt that I
will ever go fully vegan but I can't see
myself hearing more towards a
plant-based diet in the future I was a
man of my word I followed through with
the bed I ate vegan keto for a week it
was cool I feel better I learned some
things but I'm not losing the next one
[Music]